[Music]
how can we protect ourselves against
viruses we need to dig deeper to know
better where two viruses recite how do
they travel how long do they live
so viruses essentially reside in the
body of the infected human or animal
they are like parasites living off the
host organism in this case it's the
cells of an organ in which the virus
resides and replicates itself the
replicated virus looks for more cells to
attach to and infect how do they travel
when an infected person's saliva gets
sprayed in the air tiny droplets of the
saliva are sufficient to spread the
virus and the infection a sneeze can
release up to 20,000 droplets containing
virus particles that's a lot and these
particles could travel as much as six
feet so a simple precaution is to make
sure we cover a mouth before sneeze eh
how do we cover our mouth use a tissue
then dispose it off into a trash can but
what if you do not have a tissue readily
available a big no-no would be to cough
or sneeze into the fist think about it
the fist will touch several surfaces and
place the virus there for other
unsuspecting people to pick up instead
use your elbow so never cough into your
open hands or into the open air
also be considerate and turn away from
people while sneezing or coughing even
when they're talking there's a small
amount of saliva being sprayed so keep a
reasonable distance from each other and
we should all consider wearing a mask
another common way of getting infected
is through touch we end up touching a
surface which is contaminated and then
touch our mouth or nose or eyes that is
all that's needed for the virus to be
transmitted so it's extremely important
to avoid touching the face and if we do
touch our face it's even more important
to ensure that our hands are clean the
last transmission method we will look at
has to do with food intake imagine a
free-roaming insect which has picked up
the virus from somewhere this virus will
rest in the saliva of the insect when
this insect settles over some fruit it
will transmit the virus onto the surface
of that fruit if we do not wash the
fruit thoroughly the virus will be
ingested along with the fruit and now we
come to the last question how long do
you think viruses can survive on various
surfaces it varies it varies based on
the type of surface the density of the
various particles in the spray and other
external environmental conditions like
temperature humidity sunlight etc but
studies have shown that viruses could
last for as long as three days on
plastic and over 24 hours on cardboard
so to sum it all up the most important
takeaway is simple hygiene we have to
make it a way of life it's for our own
well-being and also for the well-being
of our fellow people
sneeze with the mouth fully covered keep
a reasonable distance from others keep
hands clean and avoid touching the mouth
wash all vegetables and fruits
thoroughly before consumption now before
I end this lesson I have a question for
you to keep your hands clean which is
better hand sanitizers or soap and water
in our next lesson we will compare the
two stay healthy and stay well to watch
the other lessons we've created for this
topic
[Music]